i assume trustworthy right
[Music]
oh no i like my coffee like i like my
uti
to just burn all the way down hi my name
is grace helbig if you did not know
now you know your life is different now
we're gonna go with it for today so
we're in the middle of a pandemic
because of a deadly virus and the virus
seems to be getting passed from all the
spits
that our mouth produces i'm no doctor
and i'm no scientist but if this area is
where the virus is spreading from
i think we should probably put this area
in time out for a little bit and for
some reason
that is very difficult for people to
understand isn't that wild
the bad stuff's coming from here so we
should probably plug up the bad stuff i
don't know why politics is involved in
it but that said politics also likes to
tell me
what i should put in and out of this
area
but this area could give a sh
but i give a [ __ ] even if you don't
share my belief that covering this is
helpful
i still don't want you to get sick and
that's how i go to heaven
and you don't i like to think that
perhaps some of the people that aren't
wearing masks
aren't doing it because they're just so
greedy selfish
perhaps they haven't found the right
sort of mask
that represents them and their style
that's the fun thing about masks not
only are they keeping everyone safe
medically
but they're gonna keep you cute
aesthetically today i have five
different diy mask ideas for you and i
think these five different
mask diys speak to five different types
of people so maybe you find something
that you like along the way i have not
tested any of these diys yet we're gonna
find out in real time
if this works or if the things in my
brain don't translate i also haven't
done any research to find out if other
people have done
mask diys like this i'm sure they have
our first mask is for that strong-willed
likely christian middle-aged white woman
that
loves to make her butt look like a
bedazzler used all over it so we're
gonna take an old pair of jeans
and we're going to cut out the pockets
i mean you're going to have to figure
this out for yourself all right so i've
cut out my butt let's just
cut these pockets out this butt is very
worn
i did a lot of sitting and what i'm
trying to teach you here are more
methods that you can customize
in your own special way rather than
exact diys that you should replicate
okay so we got our two pockets
and then some extra that will figure out
what to do with wow this is going to be
great so after we've cut our two pockets
i want to do some
embellishing i don't already have those
jeans that have the rhinestones all over
the butt thank god
i'm going to glue my own rhinestones on
this is the meditative process
oh my gosh that is so disgustingly tacky
it's
cute we're gonna put a j and a c just
because like you know
god
okay so camera batteries have been
charged and art
has been uh made i've fabric glued all
of my bedazzle jewels on and i also
cut out an extra piece of denim and i
attached each pocket
to the side of the denim with fabric
glue and that's going to create the
little bridge for my nose so this is
heavy as she
and loaded up with wet fabric glue so
i'm going to let this dry for a little
bit
[Music]
our next diy mask idea is for those that
want to inspire others by their
usage of wearing a mask for this diy
we're going to use a mask
that i bought at a joann fabrics while i
was in line to check out
and we're going to use some iron-on
letters i think that's a really fun cute
way to take a boring mask and
personalize it with a message of
encouragement or
scolding whatever direction you want to
take it i have an iron again this is
just the technique and you can customize
this however you want i just cut out the
letters that i want to use and i'm going
to place them on my mask and iron them
on
i probably shouldn't iron direct on my
desk but do as i say
not as i do but also do as i do
okay let's let's let's calm this down
you're doing a great impression of those
orange county housewives and then we're
going to peel back the paper and reveal
you have a perfectly customized mask
that sends the message that allows
interaction between you and strangers
when you go out into the real world
[Music]
this next diy mask is for those of you
out there who are like me
that might feel a little anxious when
you have a mask covering your mouth and
nose i get very claustrophobic
especially if my breathing is restricted
at all and from what i've seen and heard
a lot of other people
are using that as the reason that they
can't wear a mask
but i have what i think is a great
solution and for those of you that
really do
have uh medical breathing issues i'm
very sorry
maybe this will work for you or maybe
this is just stupid and doesn't work for
you for those of you that are claiming
breathing issues
i think this might help you out so what
you'll need for this is a hot glue gun a
pair of scissors
a mask i got this stretchy kind of like
nylon-ish
material mask off of amazon for super
cheap it came in a pack of six and a
small bag either a paper bag or i'm
using dog
we're gonna take our pre-existing mask i
truly love
these kind of masks from amazon like i
said super cheap these you can breathe
perfectly through but if this isn't
enough oh guess what i got for you we're
gonna
cut a hole in the middle of the mask
right where your mouth would be now this
is an example of a terrible mask but
here we're about to fix it we're going
to take
a dog bag open up the top slide it
through the hole
and we're basically going to hot glue
down the edges of the bag
inside the mask hot glue and plastic
probably don't work together but we're
just going to try
make sure the bag is fully glued all the
way around and just like that we now
have a mask that covers your nose and
mouth and allows you room to breathe
for those that claim that they have
breathing difficulties with their mask
[Music]
on
[Music]
i feel great okay our next math diy is
for those of you
that again appreciate a cute
interactive mask that has a little bit
of theatrics but also served with
purpose in
helping you and others follow the rules
of the pandemic i went online and i
actually tried to follow a mask making
tutorial and i used some canvas fabric
and it was hard as [ __ ]
a sewing machine that i have because
guess what i have a sewing machine but i
don't really know how to use it
didn't work very well and all i got were
these two kind of shoddy looking
boob inserts for peasants you made a
mask yourself
great job we're also going to use some
rope we cut out a donut
looking shape we're going to use a hot
glue gun some scissors
and decorative items we're going to take
our donut
i'm going to turn this into a cute thing
but i gotta google it first so for this
i'm actually gonna use a red piece of
felt and i'm gonna try and make it look
like a life
saver a life preserver the metaphor here
is that these masks actually do save
people's lives wow
that doesn't look good cute
so we're gonna let that dry and like
squint our eyes at it i also am
incorporating some of this rope that i
found
it's 18 feet we only need a little over
six feet of it we're going to
tie some of it to our little life
preserver here let's see if we can hot
glue it
okay ow the thing that i haven't figured
out myself
is uh how to tie the masks on
to my face oh uh-huh i have this other
mask that came in that
collection of the nylon stretchy masks
that i got
i can glue this covering over this mask
and then i have ear holes it's gonna
look sloppy glue it all in there i have
an idea
if i want to make this really freaking
cute i'm going to take some of this
nautical rope and just trim my mask in
it that's cute as [ __ ] now we're also
going to add our little accessory to
this corner
there you go we have our cute natural
rustic nautical theme-ish kind of mask
and i'm sure you're asking
and to that i say this mask is not only
raw and natural but it also has an
interactive element that makes sure that
you and others are practicing your
social distancing correctly out in
public so i have my mask on if i keep my
light per server
like a chain wallet if i think someone
is a little too close to me i can go sir
ma'am you seem in danger and i want to
save your life
and now we are six feet apart
[Music]
it's perfect okay we are on to our last
diy mask which
really doesn't serve any purpose other
than i found some decorative bananas
at joann's fabric and i want to make
them into a mask
for this mask you're going to need some
plastic bananas and a mask to glue them
onto
i found this scary little alien mask you
could probably use this mask
as a mask out in public but that's
horrifying because i don't want this to
cover my whole face
i'm going to take my glasses and try and
cut right above you could use this as
this but i thought it'd be fun
to take some bananas wow i feel
protected and i also feel fun
[Music]
i love this for us well there you go
guys there are my five
mask diys i hope that this helped you
uh think of some other ways that you can
get creative with your masks if you
are one of those people that uh refuse
to wear a mask
you can [ __ ] directly off thank you guys
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
it if you did give this video a thumbs
up let me know down in the comments what
other kind of diys i should get into
they take me a long time to do
the results are mediocre and my house
becomes a mess it's a win-win for all of
us involved other than that i don't know
[Music]
you know what they say the more tacky
bees the closer the g's
this goes
here ready this is my impression of
still life